good evening today the United States
together with our close allies and
partners took an important first step
toward a comprehensive solution that
addresses our concerns with the Islamic
Republic of Iran's nuclear program since
I took office I've made clear my
determination to prevent Iran from
obtaining a nuclear weapon as I've said
many times my strong preference is to
resolve this issue peacefully and we've
extended the hand of diplomacy yet for
many years Iran's been unwilling to meet
its obligations to the international
community so my administration worked
with Congress the United Nations
Security Council and countries around
the world to impose unprecedented
sanctions on the Iranian government
these sanctions have had a substantial
impact on the Iranian economy and with
the election of a new Iranian president
earlier this year an opening for
diplomacy emerged I spoke personally
with President rouhani of Iran earlier
this fall secretary Kerry has met
multiple times with iran's Foreign
Minister and we have pursued intensive
diplomacy bilaterally with the Iranians
and together with our p5 plus 1 partners
the United Kingdom France Germany Russia
and China as well as the European Union
today that diplomacy opened up a new
path toward a world that is more secure
a future in which we can verify that
Iran's nuclear program is peaceful and
that it cannot build a nuclear weapon
while today's announcement is just a
first step it achieves a great deal for
the first time in nearly a decade we
have halted the progress of the Iranian
nuclear program and keep parts of the
program will be rolled back Iran is
committed to halting certain levels of
enrichment and neutralizing part of its
stockpiles Iran cannot use its
next-generation centrifuges which are
used for enriching uranium Iran cannot
install or start up new centrifuges and
its production of centrifuges will be
limited
Iran will halt work at its plutonium
reactor and new inspections will provide
extensive access to Iran's nuclear
facilities and allow the international
community to verify whether Iran is
keeping its commitments these are
substantial limitations which will help
prevent Iran from building a nuclear
weapon simply put they cut off Iran's
most likely paths to a bomb meanwhile
this first step will create time and
space over the next six months for more
negotiations to fully address our
comprehensive concerns about the Iranian
program and because of this Agreement
Iran cannot use negotiations has covered
to advance its program on our side the
United States and our friends and allies
have agreed to provide around with
modest relief while continuing to apply
our toughest sanctions we will refrain
from imposing new sanctions and we will
allow the Iranian government access to a
portion of the revenue that they have
been denied through sanctions but the
broader architecture of sanctions will
remain in place and we will continue to
enforce them vigorously and if Iran does
not fully meet its commitments during
the six-month phase we will turn off the
relief and ratchet up the pressure over
the next six months we will work to
negotiate a comprehensive solution we
approach these negotiations with a basic
understanding Iran like any nation
should be able to access peaceful
nuclear energy but because of its record
of violating its obligations Iran must
accept strict limitations on its nuclear
program that make it impossible to
develop a nuclear weapon in these
negotiations nothing will be agreed to
unless everything is agreed to the
burden is on Iran to prove to the world
that its nuclear program will be
exclusively for peaceful purposes if we
run ceases this opportunity the Iranian
people will benefit from rejoining the
international community and we can begin
to chip away at the mistrust between our
two nations this would provide Iran with
a dignified path
forge a new beginning with the wider
world based on mutual respect if on the
other hand Iran refuses it will face
growing pressure and isolation over the
last few years Congress has been a key
partner in imposing sanctions on the
Iranian government and that bipartisan
effort made possible the progress that
was achieved today going forward we will
continue to work closely with Congress
however now is not the time to move
forward on new sanctions because doing
so would derail this promising first
step they alienate us from our allies
and risk unraveling the coalition that
enabled our sanctions to be enforced in
the first place that international unity
is on display today the world is united
in support of our determination to
prevent Iran from developing a nuclear
weapon Iran must know that Security and
Prosperity will never come through the
pursuit of nuclear weapons it must be
reached through fully verifiable
agreements that make Iran's pursuit of
nuclear weapons impossible as we go
forward the resolve of the United States
will remain firm as will our commitments
to our friends and allies particularly
Israel and our Gulf partners who have
good reason to be skeptical about Iran's
intentions ultimately only diplomacy can
bring about a durable solution to the
challenge posed by Iran's nuclear
program as president and
commander-in-chief I will do what is
necessary to prevent Iran from obtaining
a nuclear weapon but I have a profound
responsibility to try to resolve our
differences peacefully rather than rush
towards conflict today we have a real
opportunity to achieve a comprehensive
peaceful settlement and I believe we
must test it the first step that we've
taken today marks the most significant
and tangible progress that we've made
with Iran since I took office and now we
must use the months ahead to pursue a
lasting and comprehensive settlement
that would resolve an issue that has
threatened our security and the security
of our allies for decades it won't be
easy and huge challenges remain ahead
but through strong and principled
diplomacy the United States of America
will do our part
half of a world of greater peace
security and cooperation among nations
thank you very much
you